so our job is to help you do a data
detox and test
you know reduce the amount of data that
is out there about you
but you decide this is the important
part
[Music]
thank you so much for being on my show
how are you good morning
i'm great thank you very much for having
me thank you for taking a time to do
this
there's a lot to talk about i've been
following for a while and i'm a big fan
and i'd love to spend our 20 minutes
talking about your journey
from a technologist to investment to
business world now to ceo
talking about that non-linear career
pathway that that
comes up so much from thought leaders
like yourself on the show
and then i would also love to to talk a
little bit about the most recent series
a investment that that you raised
completely through zoom and so we have a
lot to cover but let's go all the way
back
gal wrinkle who are you
so um i'd love to share a few words i
mean i think
i'm biased but i think i have a really
diverse and
uh i would call it a strange career so
it's all started uh like 20
25 something years ago when i was uh
eight years old
um where i started to write code and x
stuff
uh yes i know it's it's in a really
young age
uh but this is what got me eventually to
drop to the 8200 units
uh the israeli army i'm sure you're
probably familiar with that unit right
yes yes i got to be lovely so but but
tell me how did you
get to start coding at eight years old
how does that even happen
so i'm i'm a gamer uh i used to play
counter strike
uh back in the days uh and actually this
got me to land my first job in one of
the leading
game gaming companies in israel we
actually did
land parties in you know back in the
days where people brought their
computers and
big screens uh and i was
basically in charge of uh running all
the networks and all the servers
this is how i learned networks and
routers and
even to code some of the things on the
counter strike servers
um wow so yeah it's a
bizarre story but yeah this is how i go
to the
coding uh world and and this is what
developed later on to start hacking
stuff uh
so now when you're when you're saying
hacking stuff give me a little bit of
context because when i'm imagining an
eight-year-old
hacking stuff that doesn't really add up
in my mind what does that actually mean
to you
so uh i'm talking about around the at
the
age of 12 not eight this is where
heck stuff and i'm talking about
security hacking so
uh back in the days when the internet
started uh
the internet didn't have any security
proper security in place
so i started to test my skills
i don't know if you remember but once we
were downloading
uh things like servers
before tokens and that
world uh so i started to hack stuff and
you know train my
skills um yeah so this is how it started
wow okay so you so you're 12 years old
you're into pro
you're into gaming you're into hacking
and coding you get into the 8200 unit
you spend a few years as a captain right
in that unit so you're really honing
your technology skills
uh both in terms of you know leading
teams but but also hands-on learning
and then you make this interesting quick
transition to the business world
so again on that non-linear career
pathway how do you find yourself then
going into investments and i believe you
were in verizon
right and you were and you were an
investment principal in various places
how do you get there so
uh it's really good story i mean after
10 years of hands-on
um developing or dealing with technology
i just woke up one day and decided that
i want to change something in my
in my career path uh i was really good
in technology but they didn't want to
take that to the next level and you know
be a vpr endeavor or cto i decided i
want to
take my tech skills and leverage that on
the business side but as you mentioned
i had to go study that somehow so i had
i had my first computer science degree
but i didn't want to
go and do mba back then um so
yeah so i joined so i found myself
joining the venture capital community i
started with nielsen
uh the market research company uh for
toys doing early stage investments and
then i moved on to verizon
ventures as you mentioned doing later
stage investments
and i think what's what's so special
about that
four and a half years is that i had a
really
um amazing chance to get a glimpse
into the startup ecosystem by investing
in early stage
stage companies and to learn you know
business skills
product marketing hiring i set it board
meetings
and eventually in four and a half years
i had the chance to invest in 20
20 companies so i saw them developing in
in advancing in uh
from the very early stage to the very
growth
stage and i think for me an amazing
experience to acquire a lot of skill
sets
that i'm using that i'm putting into uh
that i'm putting into action right now
so you're so you pretty much created
your own form of mba right you you
it's a really interesting path that you
spend
quite a few years in technology it's not
like one or two years right it's
many years in technology you reach a
certain level where you're comfortable
enough to go and execute on a lot of
these issues but then you find yourself
in a fork in the road
where you have to decide am i going to
be a vpr d cto
or do i actually want to be on the
business side of things and know how to
actually run a company
and then you decide to go into the
investment field and now most recently
you're you you're running your own
startup so
tell me about that because first of all
i love what you're doing with mine i
think that
the story of how you raise the the money
now is fascinating but tell me a little
bit about how
you moved from vc to creating a startup
so after four and a half years doing uh
investment deals i
practically decided that i'm ready to go
back and do what i'm really passionate
about which
to start my company uh and so i
grabbed my uh two friends uh one of them
our cto gal golan who uh who and i
served uh served together in the 8200
unit
and were good friends for six years uh
it was actually my trainer so
everything that i know in my cyber
security side is
thanks to him and the third co-founder
is copy nissan who i met during my
visit career he worked at saban ventures
and when the three of us sat together
we knew that we want to solve something
that is very
painful for us personally and after a
few meetings we quickly discovered that
the three of us really understands
personal data
and how valuable and precious
is it to each one of us on the personal
level
but we quickly realized that three of us
dealt with personal data of different
people
from all kind of different angles
through our career
and we quickly realized that we know how
easily our personal data
can be exploited exploited against us
as as people uh and this is how we
thought about mine we knew that we want
to bring a consumer product
that can help people understand what
companies are doing with the data
but not only that to take an action and
to do something
about it um and i'm talking about the
end of 2017
where the gdp was legislated
um and as as vc
started to research that uh and we
quickly identified that the gdpr has
made a history in the internet
or changed the history of the internet
because it actually defined
our personal data as our own asset and
it gave us powerful rights
but here is a funny story we knew that
that regulation
wouldn't be used by people because it's
very hard and complex
so to prove that we went all around
europe asking
people in the street like we grabbed
people in the street
and asked them whether they heard about
the gdpr
and and whether they exercised any of
their rights
and can you guess what was the answer
a 100 no
what is gdpr yeah
so most of them did hear about it
because all they see
all they uh saw was their freaking
cookie consent everywhere in every site
right where you need to allow all the
time but none of them could actually
uh try to exercise his rights some of
them did
try like a small portion said that they
did want to try but it was very
complex so this is how we knew that we
have to
make it accessible to millions to
millions of people
uh because it's a very powerful right
and this is how mind started
um right so so give me a little bit of
context for those who don't
still understand the magnitude of the
problem of of private data and personal
data
what is what is the trend and how
compromised
is our personal data in 2020
so um it's a very good question so data
privacy
of data protection in 2021 we believe
that the entire market has
shift from privacy into what we
identified as a data ownership
and and why why do i say that um if you
think about
privacy uh if we wanted to protect our
privacy
we had to prevent from our personal data
to be shared with others right
to install a vpn or to use a dedicated
browser
but all of those solutions actually
change our online experience right
uh if you use a vpn to log into your
bank account
you would immediately get blocked right
so it actually changed
uh changing our online experience so we
wanted to design a product
that blends into your day-to-day and
doesn't change
any any of your any of your behavior
i mean we want to sign up to services we
want to purchase
things online we want to give our data
but that
we identify that the problem is to
manage our data
on an ongoing basis and just to give you
one
interesting insight can you guess um how
many companies hold
the average users data and i'm talking
about
companies that have actively um
collected your data from sign ups
purchases things that things that you're
doing on your day-to-day not passive
how many companies have that that's a
question
wow i i i mean as a developer myself i
would imagine that at least 90
of the companies that i'm actively
seeing in my day-to-day have
a lot of personal information about me
so so we actually have the number so the
the worldwide the worldwide average
digital footprint
consists of 350 companies
so it's 350 companies
850 companies that holding your data it
can be
email plus any other thing fast forward
social security date of birth and in the
u.s by the way it's even higher it's
550.
um so going back 500 50 companies
wow that's just uh scary yeah
so going back to your original question
we quickly identified that the problem
is
managing our data on an ongoing basis
and how
how we can make to live our data
only when we actually still using it um
and and this is and this is what
developed mine so mine is
very important small data that blends
into your day to day and allows you to
always know
where your data is and who has what
about you and then
i do want to make a distinction i i it's
important for me to make a distinction
here because i think that you know
it almost feels like the world is now
split into two
types of people there's the people that
are that love the fact that their data
is being shared and it's being used by
services
and then there's the other people that
feel like okay i we're losing our
privacy
you know companies are gonna misuse the
data and and obviously i think we can
both agree that it's somewhere in the
middle right
we want to enjoy having services
leverage
their knowledge about me so that they
can personalize my experience
whether it's offering me sharing rides
to my workplace or whatever
what is the next good purchase for me
and obviously there's
the misuse of data right so getting for
example my election
my voting habits to advertise for
campaigns
now i and i think that you know what
what you're doing here is you're what i
love about what you're doing is you're
taking back
control over choosing where do i want my
data to be so right it's not an all or
nothing approach of i don't want my data
to be shared anywhere it's saying
we understand that our data is going to
be shared i want to be able to control
where it's going to be shared in the
world right
yes and i'm so happy that you mentioned
that because to give back control to
to to users uh we call it to bring you
back the choice
right and what is so nice our product is
that as you mentioned the world today is
a binary word it's either we share our
data
or we don't but what we wanted to do
with mine
it gives you the choice to decide so the
first
phase is to basically understand uh
who has what right this is the this is
the accessibility
the 350 companies that mo people don't
have any
idea and after you do have that
understanding
you have the choice to uh to to take it
back to take your data back and and this
is the control that you mentioned
uh right and and and give you all the
data that you
need all the information in order to
take an informed choice
and in order to understand what services
you need to delete and what services you
need to keep sure as you either using
or trust them but you have the choice we
are not deciding
for you uh right but we will be there to
attack you all the time
that is it's uh changing because today
you can use a service and in a few weeks
you can stop using that
so why why why the chance to keep keep
uh keep holding your data because every
day there's a new data bridge
in the new privacy scandal and you
mentioned the election so
so our job is to help you do a data
detox and test
you know reduce the amount of data that
is out there about you
but you decide this is the important
part
i think that's just remarkable and you
know we can talk about hours
uh we can talk about data for hours and
i think that what you're doing is
insanely relevant
and i'm guessing that it's an
exponential growth the amount of data
that is being
stored on us right every with every new
platform that comes out we're inventing
new data types that are being
shared about us and i remember
distinctly with cambridge analytica when
when the report came out in 2016 just
how much
knowledge they had on so many people
you know things heuristics that the
person never even shared they never
even necessarily shared with them what
their favorite color is but they
they use heuristics to to think about
that but gal i i have to spend a few
minutes talking about your most recent
series a raise because that's it's
phenomenal to be able to do it
it's even more phenomenal to do it all
over zoom so so
tell me what what happened over there
so this is really interesting story
because uh
in the middle of it some somehow covet
started but
uh if i take you a few uh a few months
back so
um after we raised our seed round in
early uh 2019
we worked for the entire year in stealth
to develop our product and when we
we felt it's ready to hit the market we
did our official launch in europe uh but
also in product and
um and we were very surprised by the
amazing production that we received in a
very short period of time
we actually won the the first place up
of the day and week
and second place up of the on product
and
yeah and somehow it got a lot of
attention
back to us from investors uh it turns
out that a lot of investors are
uh monitoring a product hunt um and so
we started to speak with a lot of
investors and i'm talking about
um the the end of january this year
um so you know i started to jump on
course with investors i was not raising
my serious a just to share our story
right to share the vision what we're
after
and and and to develop relationships
with those investors
and then um kovid arrived and i'm
talking about march 1st
uh kovid hit europe hardly right
um and three weeks later it the us as
well
uh and i actually felt how the entire
bc the entire worldwide vc community
is like shut down or getting into a
worldwide freeze
so similarly to us being locked down uh
right in the first lockdown
uh i felt how the entire vc community
got into a worldwide freeze because and
it's
it's it's really understandable most of
them had to assess their portfolio
damages right
and to to quickly develop a plan to help
uh the companies in it right i have to
say that you know
it was a very special time i might i'm a
senior associate
in in an early stage vc firm in palo
alto and i distinctly remember
the confusion of what's unraveling
and here we are we have active
investments we have lps we have money
that is ready to be deployed into the
market
and all of a sudden we think to
ourselves well what what what is our
responsibility here and what do we do
and one of the things that one of the
key questions you start asking yourself
is
well how do we make sure that even like
how long is this going to last
and assuming that our companies are not
going to make any money until
this thing ends what is the runway that
they have and how can we support them
and it was all a very confusing time so
i can only imagine
from a startup's perspective what does
that mean to now
go and potentially go into a series a
investment
so so you're very right and luckily for
me i'm i i could uh
i could play both sides right because i
came from the vc
from the vc community and now i'm i'm
doing my own thing and
uh i actually felt that right and and
you mentioned you also work in a
individual so you know the financial
model behind vcs
and and you probably know that are
raising funds for nine years right
so i quick understand it you know covet
even if it's going to last two years
it's a really small bump
in the in the in the tail right it's not
so hard for the vcs so i just knew that
we have to you know hold down a little
bit and give the vc
some time to digest and to you know
develop the plan they need to
save some of the companies because some
industries were really affected by covet
for example the travel industry
so we started speaking with those uh
visas you know uh developed the
relationship we knew that we have to
stay a little bit
um uh like uh to to give them enough
time to develop their own strategies
but as you saw most bc were quickly
back in business right uh sure yes it
took what
three months uh so
uh yeah
and luckily for us the covet was
actually increased
the need for data privacy and data
protection
uh you probably heard about contact
tracing
location tracing so privacy 100 again
yeah so privacy was again in the major
news
uh and it was really good for us and one
of the investors that we were talking to
great inventors
um we had like monthly update calls
during that
period of time and uh around june
we were lucky enough to even around may
we were lucky enough to get a term
and around june to close the entire
round
everything everything frozoom start to
finish
the the leading partner darien shirazi
he never met
us in person uh and we had another two
vc's one from germany and another cbc
from the us
mass mutual and avengers they never met
us
and you know coming from a vinci
perspective
a vc background i never thought that
investment bills
can be done remotely you know you always
have to feel the people and to meet them
in person
with something in the vibe in like
feeling them
you know under 100
so it was a really interesting
experience to me i guess kovid
teached us that we need to uh do
business
remotely we have to because the world
have to keep
moving on uh and i guess i experienced
that
uh firsthand it was a really i think
it's a you know
i i don't know if there will ever be you
know a time again where
you know deals of this magnitude will be
made entirely through zoom i can't
imagine a society
where people deploy millions of dollars
without
without wanting to meet the other person
in person but gal i
thank you for all the amazing work that
you're doing with mine thank you for for
everything you taught me through this 20
minute leaders i i
really enjoyed it and i can't wait to
continue following the company in your
journey
it sounds really really amazing but
before we leave i have to ask you for
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
wow uh it's a challenging one uh i would
say
um i would say calm
as the first one uh maybe fearless
this is something that the daily 200
this is something that gave you a
hundred unit that has uh
to just that you can do anything that
you want
uh and i would say uh something that
would surprise
some people but funny uh so i guess that
people that know me personally could
would say that so yeah so come fearless
and
fearless and funny thank you very very
much
best of luck with with everything that
you're doing and i can't wait to keep in
touch thank you
thank you very much and i really invite
you all to um
join saymine.com and just take ownership
of your personal data and and
and really do something for the first
time i love it
bye